le gouvernement fédéral américain est
partiellement paralysé vous allez me
dire au centre-ville de washington ça ne
paraît pas vous avez raison on regarde
et on est sur le match au mans ce grand
parc où il ya énormément de monuments
derrière d'autobus derrière moi c'est un
des monuments aux soldats morts lors de
certaines guerres c'était fermé lors de
la dernière paralysie du gouvernement en
2013 cette fois ci on l'a laissé ouvert
l'administration trump a donné un mot
d'ordre bien simple on ne veut pas que
on veut minimiser l'impact pour les
citoyens pour les résidents pour les
contribuables américains ce qui fait que
le musique est juste là derrière moi en
arrière musée de l'histoire des noirs
il est ouvert aujourd'hui encore c'est
samedi c'est la fin de semaine les
bureaux derrière moi avec les toits
rouges sont des bureaux gouvernementaux
bien sûr ils sont fermés aujourd'hui
c'est normal parce que c'est la fin de
semaine
le pari des républicains c'est qu'on ne
remarquera pas énormément qu'il y à une
paralysie du gouvernement du moins pas
en fin de semaine que cette mauvaise
publicité elle ne sera pas là pour eux
ici yannick dumont baron radio-canada
washington